I'm starting with some Italian fennel  sausages fire them until colours making  sure all sides are nicely browned set  them aside  then slice treat so a spicy Spanish  sausage with a wonderful smoky taste and  fry so releases all this incredible  flavor next chopped carrots celery  garlic and add to the same pan this  keeps in all the flavor stirring the pre  lentils these are excellent for slow  cooked dishes because they retain their  firm texture and shape next add a bay  leaf and some fresh thyme sprigs  then the sausages go back in along with  chicken stock  simmer until the lentils are tender then  season to taste  finally sprinkle with chopped parsley  and serve simple to prepare a cinch to  make and pack full of delicious hearty  flavors my twist on an Italian classic  magnificent easy bolito Meester  well beautiful all that was reduced down  to this amazing nice tomato sauce grated  fresh ginger  add dried shiitake mushrooms that have  been soaked in water